alright thanks for having me I'm so I've
been working on on Jupiter well I Python
before it was called before we called
part of it Jupiter for what years I
guess about 10 years now and so one of
my main responsibilities these days is
working on Jupiter hub witches are kind
of server tools for building deploying
Jupiter hub on behalf of classrooms
research groups institutions that kind
of stuff so I'm going to go through some
of the how would you better have works
what it looks like what pieces are there
and how to deploy it and kind of what
hopefully to help you figure out if
Jupiter hub is the right tool for you
which which it may not be but we'll see
how it works and I and how you can use
it there's there's a lot of pieces so to
start out we've got a github repo that's
I'm in RK and on Jupiter PI data 2016
has some a couple notebooks with some
some examples and then some example
configuration scripts and a PDF of the
presentation and you know presentation
and if you go to the github do URL
there's actually an online HTML copy of
this that I've never done before so
we'll see how that I don't know how well
that's actually gonna work but so if you
clone this then you'll have everything
I'm going to use but I'm also going to
go through and actually do typing and
deploying and configuring as we go so
starting out who is everybody who is not
familiar with Jupiter notebooks I'm
guessing you wouldn't be asking how to
deploy them if you didn't know what they
were okay
so just some kind of this is a bit of an
overloaded term what is a notebook at
one level in a book is the document that
everybody's creating and sharing and
using for tutorials and things it's also
an environment for doing kind of
interactive exploration producing these
documents to share but the
relevant aspect for for us today is that
it's it's a web app that you know we we
made the Jupiter notebook with web UI
primarily because it's easier to write a
UI in HTML and JavaScript than a list
who to do it with blue toolkits these
days but one of the effects of that is
that you can have you know well for most
people when you're running the when
you're running Jupiter you have your
it's really a local desktop application
that happens to be where the UI happens
to live in your browser but because of
the nature of that that that server can
actually be running somewhere else so
what does the notebook web server look
like we've got the browser connects
ideally over HTTP to the notebook server
which is a tornado web server and then
that tornado web server actually spawns
these kernels that are separate
processes that it also talks over the
network to which is where when you open
a notebook and run some code that code
the text that you type into the code
cell goes over the WebSocket to the to
the web server and then that sends
builds a message and sends that over a
different network protocol built on 0 mq
to the kernel which can be written in in
our Python or Scala or C++ or whatever
your interactive data analysis language
of choices and then it comes back over 0
mq and then comes back from the web
server over over the WebSocket back to
the browser and so this kind of this
whole web server and multi kernel
architecture we really treat as a single
application so that's kind of a single
multi-process single user application so
when it comes to Jupiter hub we take
that that whole application and then we
kind of we zoom out a little bit and we
have a notebook server here this is the
same notebook server and the browser is
up here but now we've added a proxy and
then something we call the hub which has
a few pieces so this is at a high level
kind of what Jupiter hub looks like and
so Jupiter hub manages authentication so
the does regular seeing the user server
can be authenticated it isn't by default
but and the way that authentication
works is something that's configurable
and you can modify and superhub spawns
single users on demand so you visit
jupiter hub and as a user and it it will
start a server for you and then point
you to it and each user gets a complete
notebook server so it's really the same
notebook server when you're using
jupiter hub with a bunch of users each
users really getting the same notebook
server that they're used to using
it's just that process or that
collection of processes is managed by
this this hub so kind of the what
happens when a user logs in is they hit
the proxy that request is handled by the
hub the hub says I don't know who you
are so do some log in sequence which is
a something that you can do in a variety
of ways the simplest version is with a
with a basic form or you can use OAuth
with services like github and Google and
and or Shibboleth if you're at a
university and then a an object called a
spawner
says ok this user has asked for a server
I know how to make servers this is an
abstraction layer where you can have
multiple spawners that define different
ways to start notebook servers
smaller-sized ok I'm going to go off and
do my thing and create a notebook server
and then it provides the hub and here's
the network information for where that
notebook server is and the hub says ok
it tells the proxy so the proxy is the
only publicly accessible endpoint so
when you're accessing Jupiter hub from
network you you talk to this proxy
service
and depending on the URL you asked for
it gets read or it gets handled by a
different server in the backend whether
it's your personal secure server or
whether or the hub and so the hub says
hey proxy there's another server back
here that you should add a route to and
now if the URL kind of user your name
will actually be handled by your server
once your server is running and then it
sends the redirect okay everything's
running you're all logged in and then
I'll redirect you to the URL for your
server and then once you connect then
the single is a server with its
authentication mechanism says okay I got
a connection
should I when it's deciding should I
allow this this browser to take actions
to write run code open my documents
change change my files and things it
actually asks the hub you know it so you
send the browser sends a cookie saying
this is who this is and then the
singular server says okay I got a cookie
I'm going to ask the hub if this is
really ok if this person should really
be allowed to to talk to me so basics of
installation if you use Conda you can do
you can install Jupiter hub in a single
go
however Jupiter hub is not it's not in
the defaults channel for for Conda so
you need to to use the decon DeForge
channel so you can Conda install - de
Conda Forge Jupiter hub and that will
get both Jupiter hub itself and also the
proxy that is needed for Jupiter hub to
run behind or if you prefer you know the
more basic tools you can use pip to
install Jupiter hub itself whether it is
a Python package and then you can use
NPM to install configurability proxy
which is the proxy service that we sit
in front and that's a node.js package
this is the nice thing about Conda being
language-independent things we can
express cross language dependencies and
they all work and get installed and so
if you have all this then you can make
sure that you've got dependencies and
everything's working just by starting
the executables with just getting the
help output to make sure that your
imports are working you've got all your
dependencies and everything should be ok
and so I will I'm running a server over
here see that legible so make sure I've
got everything working that's oh ok
that's the way to do it so right you
should get some help output
you can check the versions that you've
got installed ideally it's 0 6 1 we're
getting good maybe I'll stop yeah look
at fullscreen
and just make it really big that fit on
screen better yeah there you'll be able
to see all my pixels all right we've got
got both our things we've got a server
we've cloned the the repo we've got less
touches as our last minute that's how we
do it and let me make that closer
to my presentation
okay and then if you've got this repo
the quickest way to get everything you
need is you can just do Conda and create
with an environment file and then this
will create a content that has your as
Python 3 so Jupiter hub only runs this
is important since it is for server
hosting stuff Jupiter hub actually only
runs on Python 3 and it only runs on
POSIX see generally Linux system so it
won't run on Windows and it won't run on
Python 2 some caveats for installation
that you need to be aware of if you're
running with local users you need to
make sure that and this this happens
with Conda or virtual and sometimes you
need to make sure that the what you
install is actually executable and
readable by all users on your system
because you're going to be spawning
processes as other users and you want to
make sure that they can still import the
packages that you have installed so if
you do if you've done like a - - user
install then things are not going to
work or if you if you're doing creating
content environments in your home
directory they may not be readable by
the other user so you need to make sure
that you're doing things in kind of a
system-wide available to everybody
setup and the way I've done this is I've
set up Conda in /opt Conda and then
that's that's accessible to everyone
rather than in my home directory or
something yeah
and then just a little plug so I
mentioned Conda Forge a little bit
earlier as the laziest way to get
Jupiter hub Conda Forge you can think of
it kind of as the scent o s - anacondas
RedHat
it's a github powered kind of community
packages community managed packages
condo packages so you can if you want to
be the maintainer of a a condo package
you can just make a pull request to -
Conda Forge and say here's my recipe
that builds the package and it's all
thoroughly tested and it automatically
builds on Windows OS 10 and and Linux
for all the Python versions and
everything so you can it's it's a very
new project there aren't very many
packages yet I added to Jupiter hub a
few days ago just so that I could say
you can install it in one line which
hasn't been true in the past yeah so I
would encourage people to add the Conda
Forge channel to their default condo
sources and participate in the kind of
for community if you if you want to be a
maintainer of a package
later on I've mentioned this early we're
not going to use docker in the very
beginning but these can take a little
while so if a little bit later we're
going to use docker spawner to to spawn
our signature servers with docker and
and the single image we're going to use
is the Jupiter hub single user image and
that's the thing that might take a
little while to download so if you want
to spin that up it should be done by the
time we get we have to use it and make
sure you have docker itself so the
default behavior of Jupiter hub is
authentication uses the pam service so
it's just local users just username
password in a simple form and it's bonds
the spawns your single user servers with
just as it just switches the user you
know a set UID and spawns the single
user server as as the real users on the
system in order to do this the hub at
the hub has to run as root in order to
have permission to become all these
other users that's not strictly true
there is actually a way to run the hub
with sudo to give it only permission to
run single user servers as other users
and not actually run the hub itself as
root but that is very complicated to set
up and fraught with the peril
so let's just check what happens when we
type Jupiter hub just to start super
help me make sure I don't have a config
file yet so if I just type to put hub
just add server it's going to refuse to
run because you really want to be really
sure if you wanna run stupid or hub
without SSL it you're going to have to
say yes I'm really sure that I don't
want this when you're running Jupiter
how people are logging in
there's credentials involved you really
shouldn't run Jupiter hub without HTTPS
and inserts and all that
so you have to if you if you really want
to run it without without that you can
read this message and it tells you how
but I won't say it out loud
and that can also be relevant even if
you are doing things appropriately if
you've got Jupiter hub behind you know
if it's if you've got SSL termination at
it at another layer you know at nginx or
some up some other server then you can
it's appropriate to run Jupiter hub
itself without SSL because the SSL
termination is happening somewhere else
so about SSL you really should be using
it with with anything that's
authenticated you can generate a
self-signed start for today's purposes
you can generate a simple self-signed
cert to use one thing to note is that
safari actually refuses to connect
WebSockets to untrusted certificates
that is any certificate where you have
to click yes i really mean to go here so
far even after you do that safari will
refuse to establish WebSocket
connections to with those sorts so you
need to have trusted actually trusted
ssl certificates you can do that by
xsplit if you're on OS 10 you can
explicitly trust certificates in your
keychain or if you have a real domain
you can use let's encrypt to have free
actually real ssl certificates on your
on your server as long as it's a real
domain
so this is actually what I've done on on
my server running let's encrypt to get
free Excel is really really easy you
clone a repo CD into it you run a
command where this is your domain in my
case this is hub tutorial that Jupiter
org and then this goes through a little
process of asking for your email address
and stuff and then it stores some
certificates and keys and things in
let's encrypt directory and so once
we've got this information we can start
configuring Jupiter house the first
thing we can do is run Super Hub
generate config why are you so far away
so we can open this generative a Jupiter
hub underscore config file which is a
Python a configuration file that we use
in all the Jupiter Jupiter and ipython
tools can open that and it shows you the
like an empty configuration file showing
what you can configure and kind of and
default values so you can uncomment
lines to set the defaults and change
them you can kind of get the gist of
what you can configure in Jupiter hub as
a starting point here and so starting
what configuration we want to do the
first thing is set up SSL so in my case
I'm running a public server so I want to
run I'm going to actually use the let's
encrypt certs that I ran that I
generated with the the code I showed on
the last slide and then I'm going to run
it on the the default HTTP port if
you're doing things locally you might
run it on you can leave it on port 8000
or which is the default and just run you
to yourself science or search
so that I don't actually type every
character in front of you so this is
what my config file looks like it's got
my my SSL credentials and then tells it
to round the default HTTP port so now if
I type Jupiter hub it finishes starting
it says okay you're running on 443 I can
accept I can access it from where I
typed at localhost but I'm actually
going to connect publicly now I've bet
that's not best I guess I can't
fullscreen anything on this display so
now I've got Jupiter have with a simple
login form I can type my name my name is
PI data today and I click login and then
what do I get I get the familiar here's
just my notebook server and so what that
did was I logged in its bond the server
as the server was not running before and
then redirected me to that and now you
can see my url is slash user PI data
that's my name and then the one edition
you have is there's no there's a control
panel button at the top that you don't
have on a normal singular server and
that takes you to the hub itself with
our very elaborate control panel where
you can go back to your server or stop
it and then start it again
so the users don't at default setup easy
just don't have a lot of control over
what's they don't have a lot to do with
hub that's giving my server and then
just go do your single user stuff okay
now where has everything gone
one thing that typically you want to do
when you've got a system-wide
installation your said Minh you want to
make sure that stuff is installed for
everybody one thing to do is install
packages system-wide which often
defaults are installing per user doing
peruse your installations and if you do
things just for you everybody else won't
have access to those and another thing
is I've mentioned earlier that Jupiter
hub itself always runs with Python 3 but
often there are people there are some
people who might prefer to run Python 2
or might have two for dependency reasons
and one of the reasons that we feel ok
making Jupiter hub require Python 3 is
that that doesn't preclude user code
from running in Python 2 it's just as
far as Jupiter is concerned Python 2 is
just yet another language just like are
just like Julia just like C++ so you can
install in this case I'm using Conda
again I can create a Conda end with
Python 2 and then the I pi kernel
package so this is the ipython package
that provides the jupiter kernel
information for ipython and then I run
this ipython in the end with Conda run
it on the command ipython kernel install
and this is system-wide by that by
default because the defaults for for the
Jupiter commands themselves are
system-wide but you have you might have
to check with your kernel what the flags
are for an actual system-wide
installation and then if I run after
having done this so if I do
Jupiter kernel spec list
I see I've got Python 3 which is
actually in my Conda end and then I've
got Python 2 in user level so I can if I
go back to my single teacher server I
can say okay I want to know what I see
I've got Python 2 and Python 3 both
available
so the first custom thing that we're
going to do is take so we've got our
simple local Pam authentication and now
we're going to tell our tell our service
to use github
ooofff and so setting up github both you
have to go visit this URLs github
settings applications new and visit that
and you get something that looks like
this
which I can actually just and I need to
give it a name this is this doesn't mean
anything
you four have tutorial a little too
small that's all to big embed URL also
doesn't matter
this is the tube garage and this is the
one that matters the authorization
callback URL and this needs to be you
should be s presumably something you're
following along and then it should be
your domain or IP which for me is hub
tutorial a Jupiter and then the last bit
will be the same for everybody
B slash hub / o a callback and then if
you register that application you will
get something looks like this with the
client ID and a client secret and so the
three pieces of information you need are
the client ID the client secret and the
callback URL and then in your - anything
go there's a file in the repository
called M that has a few shell variables
defined but not filled out so if you
edit that file and fill it out you can
specify the github client ID to get a
github client secret and then the OAuth
callback URL which should be your domain
so from from those two pick from that
github page you enter this information
to tell Jupiter up kind of how to login
with get oh yeah it what I've typed here
doesn't you you have to specify a
there's a there's another environment
variable that don't remember off the top
of my head but that you can look in
Authenticator to say but yeah it works
with github enterprise you just have to
change like the github API URL and then
it just works
yep
halfway you're halfway to not having to
run is root so running as root is
required for two things one is access to
the pam service which on a Ubuntu or
Debian system is you can also have just
by making the user a member of the
shadow group and then you don't need
root for authentication even with Pam
but where since I am I'm just using this
for authentication
the main thing where I need root is for
becoming other users as a part of the
spawner stat so I'm I'm just doing I'm
starting with just custom authentication
and then I'll switch to custom spawning
and once I've done both of those I don't
have to be rude it is it is possible
there is not a like single flag I have I
do exactly that when I'm testing I have
a simple spawner that basically mocks
out the switching the user and then it
just works yes it's not a strict
requirement it's it's specifically the
the action of switching users is what
requires route it's not the hub itself
or anything about it so if you write a
spawner that doesn't do that which could
be a subclass of the default spawner
that just removes those would be one
example of that then you would be able
to to run it as an arbitrary user
we find
looks like I have actually so I'm going
to do something
Ella's right now which is on a public
screen that's recorded I'm going to
actually look at some credentials for
being able to rent things as me which I
need to remember to delete after this
because I've deleted what I need so
here's my Jupiter hub tutorial okay my
client ID and my client secret in case
you want to build an application that is
authenticated as me
so my client ID GLAAD secret
all right so now I've got those
environment variables
okay
so now I can edit my configuration file
again and tell so now that I've got the
information I need to do a lot with
github we need to actually tell Jupiter
hub how to do that so o auth for Jupiter
hub is provided by an external package
called OAuth authentication so our
authenticators are called our
implementations of authentication are
called authenticators the OAuth
implementation is called a Authenticator
and then once we have the package that
actually provides the implementation in
our config file and this is because
we're still using local users we're
going to use the local github of
Authenticator and that is authenticate
loketh entick eight github users and
then as an additional step if though if
that username doesn't exist on my system
actually create a user on the system you
don't need that if you kind of if you
already create those usernames before
starting Jupiter hub then you don't need
you don't need this extra flag but since
I'm starting on a server that I just
created for this this tutorial that has
no users on it I need to specify that
and then I go back to my config file
which
I can stop Jupiter hub and start it
again
and let's see what happens
where did you put a one
so now instead of a form I just get one
big button that says sign in with get up
and I'm going to do this in a private
window so that it shows all the steps
like that that says github Roth stuff
login to github two-factor
authentication with my phone
which I will give one second before
giving up
and then I'm back this is except now if
I start my server and see that I'm
actually min RK now instead of instead
of by data because that's my github
username you also see on the control
panel because I'm in RK now I am admin
on the server which will show how to
make that happen
and so there's an extra button which
lets me see kind of all the users I've
got and I can stop stop other people's
servers see who's running see how long
it's been since they've been since
they've logged in that kind of stuff I
can add new users to the to the server
but of course what I've done with the
config so far the default behavior of
Jupiter hub is that any user that
successfully authenticates is allowed to
login and this is fine for Pam because
if you've got users on the system it's
reasonable not necessarily what you want
to do but it's reasonable to say anybody
who can log into this system
can log into Jupiter hub and use it
however with github the way I've set it
up
anybody with github credentials can log
in and use my instance and it will just
create a user for them so I've now
created a public server on the internet
for everybody on github so to undo that
Juber hub has this notion of a whitelist
the user whitelist so the whitelist is a
set a Python set of user names of who
should be allowed to use it and then
admin users is a separate set for who
should be allowed to who should also be
an administrator who can get to that
admin panel and can do things like stop
other people's servers in case you know
something got stuck I need to clean up
or I want to you know I want to shut
down things that are taking up too much
resources or I want to see what's going
on those are what I think the kind of
things administrators can do so there's
two lists yeah
in this instance yes there is a dick you
can use a dictionary map if you want to
map github user names to system user
names that are different you can have a
dictionary that just does a lookup so
it's what what it's doing actually is
it's doing a lookup in that dictionary
and but you know default value of no
change yes you can have you can have a
system with real users and use github
login for that and have to github users
names do not have to match the system
user names
so you can look at authenticators
themselves now that I've thoroughly
confused my tabs in the repo there's an
authenticators notebook we're going to
look at a little bit about what what
makes an authentic air work we're going
to import some up authenticators the
Authenticator base class let's make
these a little bigger and then we're
going to look and the Pam which is the
default Authenticator and we're look at
the authenticate method this is this is
where if you have a form Authenticator
this is really all there is to it is a
method that's given the HDP handler that
is being authenticated and then form
data and if we look at how the Pam
Authenticator is implemented it just
gets the username field out of the form
and the password field and then calls
Pamela as a Python binding for Pam and
it just says authenticate and if it
authenticates then you return the
username and that's following for NATO
conventions of you return the username
of you are authenticated as and then you
return none if you're not authenticated
as anybody so writing form based
authentication especially if it's just a
username and password and doesn't
involve any additional information is
really really simple so if you've got
some other service that needs if you've
if your username and password login
setup is if it integrates with Pam then
you don't actually need to do anything
because Pam is you you tell Pam to talk
to your service and then this jibra hub
doesn't need to know that it's not just
talking to the the password file so that
since it is using the Pam API but if for
some reason you can't use Pam and you
need to use form you know username
password login in some other way you can
just write that implementation that is
either wrapping an API or just your
local implementation so here is an
example Authenticator a totally complete
valid Authenticator that actually works
that is called secure authentic
gator that has an extremely rigorous
authentication mechanism so I can
instantiate one of these guys
and then the form data let's say is me
username password yeah okay so I thought
to get that I get nothing back that
means I'm not logged in but if I enter
my password then it tells me who's
looked so if you want to do an exercise
of kind of get a feel for how to write a
custom Authenticator you can this is
something that people have asked for for
testing for or for even writing
encapsulated services right on an
Authenticator where passwords are loaded
from a dictionary somewhere and you can
use that to just say I've got passwords
here shove them in a dictionary and then
check them and then since it's generally
ill-advised to store passwords in
clear-text ever anywhere and this is
relevant to some other things that you
put hub does what just in Jupiter have
actually has a couple of utility
functions for hashing something and then
a comparison function for given the
clear text thing and a hashed salted
string tell me if they're if they're
equal so what this does is it generates
some salt dessert just password storage
standard standard things and then you
can given given a clear text passwords
say is this does this match what I've
stored right so if I just to verify that
it's not a lie not just always returning
true oh whoops
oh yeah
no that's doing it's just it's
generating its reusing the same salt
hashing it again and then showing and
then comparing the result
and one thing about the for doing
experimentation mocking testing one
thing about these Python configuration
files is they can include your class
definition
right so this this is an actual
configuration file that defines what
secure Authenticator means and then uses
it I won't actually do this
okay pretty good on custom
authenticators
so our next step is telling superhub to
use docker instead of creating instead
of switches switching to users on the
local system and spawning spawning the
server as those given as those users if
you use docker spawner just like we've
got authenticator it's packaged docker
spawn as a package then we're also going
to use meta faces just for a convenience
thing you don't actually have to but I
like it
and then and then we're pulling our
image that hopefully we did earlier so
we've got we're switching from local
github which is mapping to local users
to just the basic github Authenticator
which is a simpler class that just
doesn't check if the users are on the
system it says I've logged in as a
github user here's the username I don't
check anything on the host system at all
so we're moving backwards a little bit
in that we're not using local anymore
we're just using github and then we're
using docker spawner just fine our
doctors
I think I missed
yeah and we also want our whitelist
okay so now we're using the freezing
github and we're using docker and then
if we try this initially it won't work
because of one one missing piece and
that's that the hub it's API we remember
when I started I said that the sync
leader server asks the hub if the if the
cookie is valid if if the browser trying
to visit a single user server should be
allowed and that means that the that the
sync user server needs to be able to see
the hubs API and the hub's API listens
on localhost only by default which means
that these things that your server can't
actually see it if it's isolated in a
dark manner so this little snippet just
says you know so when you when you have
docker it creates a virtual Ethernet
interface that is typically called
docker zero you can you can find you can
find this manually and just hard code it
if you run something like I have config
you can see I've got network interfaces
I don't want and then I've got Dockers
zero as a network interface the docker
created when I installed the docker
engine so this is my IP address and that
little bit of Python code with meta
faces is basically just reading this
information in a programmatic way so
that it's always correct
Hey
so now I've got Jupiter hub configured
to use github for auth make sure yeah
and docker for spawning so now instead
of instead of log instead of creating
the service section creating the single
user process locally it's going to
create a docker container when I log in
hopefully yes that's what I'm that's
what I've asked it to do I start Jupiter
hub and I didn't install native faces oh
no I just didn't import it
right
now let's see what happens if I walk in
sign in I'm logged in I can start my
server and what are the chances of a 500
error good enough yeah okay took a
little longer because when I logged in
and said oh there's no container for you
I have to create that container for you
and created that container started the
server in there and then redirected me
to it is in the same way it did with the
local thing as far as the hub is
concerned it doesn't really care it's
the the single server is just a network
service that's running on some IP
somewhere that I have access to and
that's all that matters
so if I start a terminal for one you may
notice that the files available to me
are different if I start a terminal that
kind of has to be small I can do like
hostname is if you've used docker before
you're used to short hex host names +
and Who am I
my name is Jovian because the docker
containers by default use this Jovian
username of it so everybody everybody
who logs in will get their own docker
container and be isolated from each
other at least as far as the as far as
docker does by default
as with docker there's a lot you can do
with docker spawn or doctor spawn are
exposes most of what you can do with
docker because there are an unreasonably
number of reasonable things to do with
with docker
I'm not going to all of them but
standard things to do are set up docker
overlay networks to kind of limit the
network access that containers have but
also grant them access to data services
so if you're running a database that
you're that could also be in a docker
container that your users should have
access to you can use docker to set that
up data volumes for you know if they're
presumably their user data should
persist somewhere you can mount data
volumes that either are you know real
data sources for databases for data sets
or they can just be you know mount the
home directory for them to store their
notebooks in because what I've done by
default is it just created a container
their home directory is somewhere if I
delete that container all their data is
gone but if you use a data volume then
you can delete the container without
deleting their data those are separate
storage entities and you can also
specify a custom image so there's a
default image that's just it's got some
Syfy stuff you know basic playing around
with with Jupiter things and ipython you
can specify your own docker image it
needs to have the single user launching
script and there's that in fact a script
in the docker spawner package for given
any docker image make it usable as a
single user image and we've talked about
doing that at runtime but it doesn't yet
and there are a variety of docker stacks
that the jupiter folks have provided
with different with our and yeah
I have an exercise where you can learn
how to do that yes it's like other
things it's not a flag but it's possible
yeah there's there's something that I'll
show you shortly that is a so when I
click getting my server it's taking me
Drake straight to my server you can in
your in your as the system in in your
configuration say that should actually
go to a form where they can express some
preferences and then that form is
interpreted by the spawner to do
arbitrary things and one of those things
could be to just start a different image
another one could be to actually pull
weight because if you just change the
image name might say I don't have that
image another one might be to pull it
another one might be to do what binder
does and actually clone a github repo
add it to your base image and you can
you can do arbitrary things with the
with the farm so a little bit of
customizing spawners we're going to hop
back over to notebooks and peek it
spawners spawners have a bit there's a
bit more to them than authenticators
because there's a lot of them you can
environment variables arguments this
options form this is the option what I
was mentioning of a way for the spawner
to say I should show a form instead of
just get started like I have so these
things are configurable but when we talk
about configuration we really mean the
person a single configuration for the
application but then this this options
are kind of user preferences expressed
at spawn time
an options from forum is a function for
turning the horrible ugly HTML form data
that's always a list of strings into
that's fine I've got it open multiple
times that's a problem
yep and then get args gives you the the
command-line arguments for starting the
server start is the the method that
actually starts the process and then we
can look at what does start look like in
the default implementation and it just
says you know al-qaida random port give
me my environment
give me my arguments to pass and then P
open then this make pre exec function is
actually what sets the user so in Python
with P open pre exec is a Python
function that runs before actually as a
part of the process switching thing so
this this make pre exec is actually how
it switches users and so if you wanted
to write that custom spawner that just
doesn't do that if you made this make
pre exact if you subclassed
and then made make pre exec just return
a empty lambda that's exactly what it
would do that wouldn't quite work
because of some stuff with home
directories you probably it would still
try to switch to the home directory I
think but that that that's most of it
this is what a spawner form looks like
and here is an example demo form spawner
that just says an options form and what
you give is as just as a string the body
not the entire form but the body of an
HTML form which in this case is just a
single string input and then options
from form is what takes that form data
which is going to be keyed by the the
names of the inputs and then it's always
going to be a list of strings because
that's what tornado does
with forms and then you can do things
like casts numbers and/or split a string
into an argument list and then what we
do in this case what this does is give
you a form for adding extra arguments
and so from the options form and get the
arguments and then we ask for those
arguments from user options so
self-taught user options is where the
options are stored when start is called
so get args gets we're adding extra
arguments the default and in this case
you've got get n does we're not doing
anything extra but this is where you
would add extra environment variables so
if I took this spawner
and found
so if I actually run with this
and go back to local github
so I can run again and
and now if I go to log out now instead
of when I click start my server I get
this spawn form instead of actually just
going to my server and I can do - -
debug or whatever I can even this is you
know there's a there are potential
issues with giving users control over
these things because I can do like - -
unrecognized flag that's fun oh I missed
an important so I got an that time I got
an error because it didn't interpret the
form properly
yeah I should be okay
unrecognized
so I specified a flag gave it something
that it doesn't actually understand and
then after a little while it's going to
say yeah
oh I failed to start so I gave it
something I actually didn't work I can
just do debug and that'll just add a
bunch of logging and it will fail for
other reasons I think I've got some
cookies messed up yeah yes you need to
be careful when you're giving users
influence over your or what's going on
but for simple declarative stuff that
aren't arbitrary things like command
lists you can be more sure that you're
doing something safe
yes so that yes so if you want to
specify so you can have options that are
per user that you specify that users
don't specify you can have that without
needing anything like this you can just
have your spawner says you know in get
Nvidia's set a bunch of environment
variables for this user because when
that's called you know what user you're
being called for ID so a spawner in in
terms of Jupiter hub the each user has
in the process each user has a spawner
instance so if I if I have a spawner
I've got self that user is an object
containing information about the user
I'm about to spawn a server for and so
you can have get n or get args or even
start at do different things depending
on what user is and if you're doing that
then you don't you don't need to have
things like expose options to the user
so there's there's three levels of
there's global options that affect
everybody there's options that are
interpreted per user and there's options
specified by the user
okay
I'm going to find everything in
so docker spawners start let's look at
kind of their implementation there's a
bit more to it because it's loading a
bunch of docker options for creating the
container and all that but doc respond
actually takes some arguments these
arguments are generally passed but
they're useful for subclasses to say
given take start and then actually
provide something to super so here we're
saying given an image start a container
with that image what you could do as an
exercise if you like is make a smaller
form just like we did with the the demo
with the adding arguments make a spawner
form that lets you pick the image that's
used for for each forgiving user so we
saw in the example where was the example
we have options form defines what the
contents of that form are options from
form basically takes a dumb HTML form
dict and turns it into a nice dicta VAR
actual interpreted options
and then we can access the contents of
that during start with self-taught user
options which is a dictionary that
always may be empty it's always allowed
for that to be empty so you want to you
know use get and defaults and things so
with that information and then looking
at the doctor spawner let's start you
should be able to write a in your config
file subclass blocker spawner define a
form that lets you pick from an image
and then change start to load the image
from user options instead of self dot
imaging
now if you're really ambitious instead
of just changing the image value and if
you're familiar with the duck or Python
API then you could subclass options form
to do something like point it at github
repo and then when the user spawns
actually create a new image that adds
some steps for cloning a github repo to
initialize kind of the state and then
use use that image that's going to be a
different image for every user and start
and that's basically what in in a lot of
respects that's basically what binder
does and then this would be a way to do
that in Jupiter hub as well
I don't know if anybody actually wants
to do these things
guessing the answer might be no yeah
there is not immediately so that that
Jupiter hub is as it works right now is
really about isolating users from each
other rather than collaborating with
each other possibly there there's a
thing called sage math cloud that has
real-time collaboration on the notebooks
and we are working on adding that kind
of functionality to Juba Rob that mainly
that functionality actually needs to be
added to the single user notebook and
then Jupiter hub would just be used for
kind of identifying and authenticating
but because since most of what Jupiter
up does is spawn a notebook server the
collaboration really is just in pointing
to people at a single web app and having
that work yep yep
yes the authentication piece would be
provided by your pet hub yeah and then
so we are in an error term things like
higher latency collaboration things like
publishing sharing but not a real-time
yep
there is one on the Jupiter hub org
there's a COO base Bonners kubernetes
that's written by you UV at Wikimedia I
am not aware of one for mezzos the main
thing in the way of spawning on mezzos
or yarn or something is usually their
lack of a good Python API yeah yeah so
it's the it should it's totally doable
if you've got a mechanism for spawning
processes you can do it with Jupiter hub
it's fine the only thing you all you
need to do is know how to start a
process and then get network information
about the IP and the port of where that
ended up and that's all you need to know
to write a spawner and so usually that
involves kind of what is the API that I
can call from Python whether it's a REST
API or something for actually making
that request and with a lot of the
Apache and Hadoop stuff those api's
exist but in most of them nobody's
bothered to write a Python wrapper but
there's only a Java client that you can
look at and then okay I know how to make
those requests and it's it's it's more
work than maybe it should be but it's
not it's not hard especially if you're
already familiar with spawning things on
Maysles and i believe there is some work
on a project wrapping yarn specifically
with a with a nice Python API
that's a relatively recent level but if
you've got if you've got a mechanism for
spinning up processes you can use it in
Jupiter hub V so the ones that exist now
are there's a remote one that actually
is being used at Brookhaven where
they've got kind of beamline machines
and they want people to be able to log
in and say I want to start my server
physically on this particular machine
and they get a little form with the drop
down saying I want to start it there and
it does some ssh stuff too to start it
over there in forward ports and things
and then there's at UCSD supercomputing
Center or the San Diego supercomputing
Center at UCSD they have one hooked up
to their kind of PBS HPC system for
submitting notebook servers during do it
using traditional batch cluster stuff
so yeah if you can start a process
somewhere you can use that to run with
zero
we talk about just starting it manually
but often when you're you know you start
you want to use kind of operations tools
standard system management tools for you
know making sure they stay up if they go
down and I want to be able to check on
their status there there are tools
system D in it supervisor what-have-you
for managing processes this is an
example of a configuration that I
typically use supervisor when I'm
deploying Jupiter hub it lets you do
simple things like started automatically
restart it if it goes down send standard
error and stand it out to a standard log
file you know run it as a particular
user with most of these things if you're
used to running things in a service type
setup you may be familiar with the fact
that it starts out with a unreasonably
bear environment that frequently when
people say all right start a service
then why is my path wrong why is my
locale wrong so I pretty much always
even though you can have the command to
be just Jupiter hub I pretty much always
wrap any service I do in a shell so that
it actually loads some environment
variables and gets a kind of a more
reasonable environment in which to run
sometimes I'll even do a full login
shell and then you use exec izi is a
handy thing for I started a shell but I
don't actually want it to be a sub
process of the shell exec replaces the
shell process with the Jupiter hub
process which is handy for this can
actually be useful in your single user
servers so maybe you want your single
user server to activate the Conda
environment to actually source all your
bash login shell environment stuff if
you change the Jupiter hub can make the
single user Jupiter app command from the
default Jupiter hub single user script
to a bash script that does sourcing a
bunch of stuff and then you the last
thing you do is exec Jupiter
single-user and then it will do all the
stuff you wanted before and then become
Jupiter hub become the Jupiter server
but without adding a process in the
middle that can cause things to get
messed up so exactly is a useful thing
and then it looks similar if you're
using you know service or system de or
whatever just whatever whatever you
decide to use but the same principles
apply wrapping up I believe we have
working on some reference deployments so
there are many options and we've gone
through just a tiny tiny fraction of
them there are many things that you can
control with Jupiter hub and to help
with some of that and best practices and
things we are putting together reference
deployments of Jupiter hub one using a
doctor set up a purely docker setup so
the hub is in doc container we didn't do
that today
the and it's spins up with docker
compose and uses docker volumes to share
data around and automatically runs let's
encrypt to generate your SSL certs if
you want you can specify an image these
are these are in early stages and so for
getting kind of more quickly up and
running with kind of what we consider
reasonable defaults and then you can
take that and change what you want to
protect your needs another we're doing
two of these work for now that are very
very different from each other so that
one just uses docker compose which is a
tool for setting up a multi docker
application and the docker deploy
teaching is specifically for use for
setting up super hub for a classroom or
workshop or something and it adds to
Jupiter hubs something called env grader
which is written by Jess Hamrick at UC
Berkeley for actually doing automated
grading of notebooks as assignments and
turning them in grading them with a form
turning them back in with partial credit
and prose comments and you can have you
know assigned graders in your class and
even properly anonymized grading so you
don't actually see the name of the
person whose assignment you're grading
because she's in psychology and the
the little blind stuff is important to
them it's a really cool project and then
this teaching deployment uses ansible
and runs real users on a single system
but it still uses github both of these
use github OAuth to log in because what
there's nobody likes dealing with
passwords and yeah I think I've got a
going through the whole docker to plan
but I'm not going to do that I think
maybe I'll just stop and take questions
if I'm my interpretation of the clock is
correct I can I can do yeah if people
want to want me to talk about something
in particular I do have more I can talk
about but yeah persist users data yep
you could use volumes are you also
mentioned putting that's a database
that's running in another container on
the same network as
so it is my intention and it was my
intention to actually have the docker
the reference docker deployment actually
be running the database in the just even
the hubs database in Postgres in a
container I didn't get around to that
there are deployments of Jupiter hubs
that are already doing that it's not
mounting it in the user container it's
bounding it in the hub container but
it's the same principle I don't have one
off the top of my head that I can like
to four so I do have
here's a primitive example
of persistence so this is a really
really simple deployment that I ran for
a workshop at Simula where I work in
Oslo and the main thing it does is that
it has this nike spawner Mikey use the
name of the machinery on which in start
all it does is make sure there's a home
directory so the persistence is just a
directory on the host system in this
case and then I the only reason this
stuff is here is because if I mounted a
location that doesn't exist in docker it
will be owned by root and that means
that people can't write to it which
misses the point a little bit so I just
made sure that it was in this case it
was fine for it to just be global
writable because I create a home
directory and then each container mounts
slash home slash user name so even
though all the containers are running is
the same user they're all able to mount
a home directory and write to it and in
this case I wasn't I didn't have to be
root to run this and then the config
file looks like docker spawn or dot
volumes it says just mount this work
directory in the container amount of
work directory from the host machine
that is a per user location and in this
case this is user data persistence just
on the host file system but you could do
the same thing if instead of instead of
a regular instead of a host volume you
could just use a docker volume for the
same thing
and typically it would be reasonable to
in just hammer X deployments
she just mounts their entire home
directory I couldn't do that here
because the base image I used actually
installs software in the home directory
so if I mounted it then that software
would it be available I I think you had
two questions and I've forgotten what
the other was
oh yeah a database so in for the
database stuff often you just need and I
you know IP port it may may be
credentials so if I do models I believe
it is in here this is just a marks
deployment
maybe hard-pressed to find things
promptly
I don't think this is right
I don't have it but yet so she has a
deployment where you can see in the hub
container it in the specification for
the hub container so there's there's a
container that runs a Postgres database
and then in the hub container it mounts
it sets up the network a docker link so
that the the hub container has access to
the database and then specifies a couple
environment variables for authenticating
with the database and so you could in
your spawner set up links this is what
in in docker the Dockers network could
like peer-to-peer connections
it calls links so you can set up when
you're setting up a container you create
a link to your database container and
then maybe you specify some environment
variables that allow the user to be
authenticated with that database even as
themselves not depending on the nature
of your your system maybe that's a
specific authentication that should be
separate per users or maybe it's just a
password that everybody just has a right
access and they're not uh they're not
identified as a part of the
authentication but you could have in
your start mechanism specify environment
variables or what have you
the simplest way to scale so there's
there's the simplest way to scale is to
just say sub docker for docker swarm and
docker swarm is just docker that it's
just it's a cluster that looks like a
single docker instant you don't actually
have to change anything so you just use
docker spawner and then you in your
docker config you're pointing it to a
swarm instead of a local dr. instance
and then you've got a elastically
scalable yatta it's error the other
thing is basically it lives in the
spawner is where that information would
live in the it supports that in that all
you need is the spawner knows how to
start the notebook server somewhere and
then return back an IP and a port for
where it is so that I can check if it's
still there and so the proxy can send
requests to it so if you've got a in
some sense the answer is Jupiter hub
itself doesn't do things like scaling or
anything that's kind of badass cop for
the project but because there are a
million other things for given compute
resources allocate them appropriately
and distribute things and Jupiter hub is
written to kind of minimize the amount
of information it needs about the
context in which the thing user servers
are started so there are someone has
written an ec2 spawner that actually
spins up an ec2 instance for each user
and that should be scalable to
relatively large numbers in terms
especially in terms of cost the there
are PBS minors UCSD is using PBS so it's
actually using the batch the existing
batch system on you know 30,000 node
supercomputers to allocate notebooks
wherever so it's really it's up to
either the spawner itself or the
so docker has its own API for some of
those things and you can specify them in
the banks like extra container arguments
or something you can specify memory
limits and CPU limits and things I think
there there are there's a subset of
things that are easy to limit and I am
not super familiar with where the
boundaries of those are usually I set
CPU and memory limits and stop there for
things like sis calls to protect against
like fork bombs and process counts and
and things those are available to
varying degrees and often you can do
that globally at the docker level and
with antsy groups I don't know too much
about the details of kind of what what
is configurable at what level and what
is what is easy versus what is hard to
limit but in since docker spawner is
just kind of creating a container
there's if you look up the docker don't
look up how to do it with dock respond
or look up how to do with docker and
then just you'll be able to you should
be able to just do that
yeah
yet technically there's nothing in
Jupiter hub that actually requires that
these single user servers it's starting
our Jupiter it just needs to be a web
server so you can use Jupiter hub to
spawn web servers of any kind and
authenticate them and the senior servers
for the most part don't know that
they're being run in Jupiter hub as we
add the real-time collaboration stuff we
will add kind of some ways for it to
behave differently when there's the
notion of other users the notion of Who
am I and stuff but right now there's
there's very little of that information
that gets into from the hub that gets
into the single Joe Scheffer I do want
to mention some yeah skip through this
is just the the process for running the
the doc buzz recipe some things to do
that I didn't cover always use SSL I did
cover that you huge Postgres for the
host database instead of SQLite that has
various benefits people put nginx in
front of the proxy for performance
reasons you can serve if you put nginx
in front you can serve static resources
from nginx so that you're not always
going through the proxy and then hitting
single user servers to get the static
JavaScript and HTML and stuff that each
of the single user servers you can
actually have them all served directly
from nginx which saves some load
colloidal service servers is a script
that's in the examples that will shut
down single user servers when they've
been idle for a while the default is to
just leave all those decisions up to the
users or admins that it Jupiter hub
won't clean up your stuff that's up to
you but one of the ways that can be up
to you is a you can run a service next
to it Jupiter hub has a REST API that
covers basically everything Jupiter hub
can do you can do with Jupiter hub from
an adjacent service using the REST API
and Cole idle service is one of the
examples of that that says just check
every once in a while and say if if this
server has been that bin has
done anything for an hour for a day shut
it down and you can Jupiter on my Python
support configuration coming from like
system-wide locations you can have
things like install current we talked
about installing kernels and packages
you can also do things like specify
configuration of ipython and Jupiter so
loading extensions this is anything in
notebook 4.2 but you can say all of my
instances should actually load this
extension that maybe adds some widgets
or whatever for your your in-house tools
and stuff you can make sure that that's
installed for everybody without having
to go say for everybody
install it you can just install ting
system-wide configure defaults and some
white and backup your data so one of the
one of the things that this did happen
um one of the suggest Hamrick was one of
the first people to deploy a large scale
largest scale class well large for class
of a couple 225 students using Jupiter
hub and using her and be greater
software and it was go and using docker
swarm she was actually one of the first
users of maybe the first user of docker
swarm in production basically she was
saying okay she was using docker and
then the docker folks said basically a
week before class started hey we're
gonna we're trying to make this docker
swarm thing and so she started using it
for her class and everything went great
for the entire semester until like the
the weekend when they are doing their
take home final and the actual physical
node so we were running on Rackspace
machines and with on metal instances so
it's a real physical server and it just
died and
just as a prudent sysadmin and
everything so everything was backed up
and the deployment was all these ansible
scripts and things so he was able to
just restore from backup ansible deploy
it all came back up but that was a
nerve-racking Saturday but it was it
turned out fine because she backed up
there yeah and a little thing I'd like
to finish with maybe is when you should
use Jupiter hub yeah
so you can two answers to that what yes
right so that yeah the question was
about this is focused on this is good
for notebooks but what how we thought
about editing files that aren't
notebooks and how how to do that well
there's two answers to that one is that
and this is largely because of Jupiter
hub that we have this as soon as I find
what's going on it's not really easy
maybe
No
what's going on
No
laughs everything's everything's falling
apart it's a good thing we're oh you
came back oh yeah we have documentation
of the rest API with swagger so you can
see kind of what's available
yeah that's okay
yeah so I can make say a new text file
so jus the single-user server does
actually come with a basic text editor
really it's very primitive it's just
putting code mirror on the page and
you've got things like you know you can
open terminals and things so we do we
are aware that there are cases where
this is your only window onto a machine
so there is a terminal and a plain text
editor it's not going to compare to your
real tools unless you're actually a
memory max person in which case you can
just use it in the terminal just work
since fine I'm not one of those people
so it it is something we thought about
but the scope of how much we're putting
into that is is not you know our bash
our ambition is not to make the next
great text editor and a web browser
although it will improve to some degree
with the next iteration of our single
user server JavaScript UI stuff is being
basically completely rewritten in a way
that will actually make this kind of
stuff nicer that it has some kind of a
panel I can open a text editor a
notebook next to each other in the same
window and file browser and terminals
and pane link and so that will make
things like Jupiter have nicer for
working with not just notebooks
I may have one instance that I can
actually use nope okay yeah yeah I think
I wanted to finish with ya so if you've
got a class or workshop the super hubs a
nice way to say you guys don't need to
install anything I've got I've got it
covered
I've got the dependencies all the
versions you need access to data sources
you know whatever and if you've got
using some that can be greater can
actually Juba Rob helps you distribute
assignments and help students turn in
assignments so that you don't need to
deal with email or CMS's or stuff like
that or if you've just got some
computing resources that people already
have access to and they want to use
notebooks but maybe not but maybe from
home they can use you can stand up to a
better hub and there have there been a
number of people where we've got a
workstation people are everybody
starting their own and then doing a
reverse SSH tunnels to their own things
and with superhub and like all the
defaults on should be a strict
improvement on that because you're just
you running your notebook server on as
your user on your system that you've
already been running notebooks on it's
just more convenient to start and stop
everything or if you've got you know
cluster resources like san diego or
things that can be useful portal set up
when not to use it and this is something
so Jupiter hub is authenticated and
persistent so you log in your real
person your user Joe grabbed knows who
you are you and your stuff sticks around
you know you log in it leaves your
server up it takes a bit of work to kind
of confined Jupiter hub resources not a
lot but a little temp and B is another
thing we do that is related to but
doesn't actually have any shared code or
anything with Jupiter top temp and B is
so where Jupiter hub is authenticated
and persistent temp MB is anonymous and
ephemeral and so if you go to try
Jupiter org that's a portal to a temp MB
instance and that just it doesn't ask
who you are
it just when you hit that URL it spawns
a
or it doesn't spawn it gives you a
docker container that you can use and
then if you're gone for ten ten or
fifteen minutes that our retainer is
destroyed so if you want to and that's
that's all docker based it's a single
docker image for the whole instance so
if you've got a library that's say I
want to stand up I want to say I've made
a cool thing maybe it's a data set maybe
it's a library I want people to be able
to play with it
ten pen B might be what you actually
want to deploy not Jupiter hub because
then people you don't have to ask who
people are they can just come play with
it then and they won't leave a mess
because anything they make will get
cleaned up and binder is basically ten
pen B + github repo so if you haven't
seen binder it's super super cool it's a
run by Jeremy Freeman and others at and
they basically it says take temp and B
but instead of a single static image
like try Jupiter a lot of people when we
stood up try Jupiter a lot of people
we're asking hey can I just get my stuff
in there because I want to use your free
computing resources and we don't do that
but that's basically what binder is is
it says you give it a github repo that
has your data your notebooks and then
maybe a requirements file or a Conda
environment file and then you say binder
hey here's here's a github repo that has
some stuff in it and what it does is it
creates a docker docker image that
actually loads your data and installs
any dependencies and that anybody can
visit you just click a link and then it
spins like temp MB an ephemeral instance
but with all your all your data and
notebooks installed and so that's really
useful for if you want to have kind of
free live documentation of of your
library so tasks distributed has some
really nice examples and you just click
a link and you can run desk and play
with it and and and do stuff and you
people don't need to log in it's free
it's going to stay free because it's
part of a kind of an open reproducible
science initiative that is the point of
it
so being free is the point of it
it's not a lost leader market whatever
okay stop there
on stage my cloud is also if you want
real-time collaboration today use fake
math cloud it exists it works it's good
and it you don't have to do suicide
men's stuff which well I'm here to
explain how to do suicide my stuff it's
not always what you should do yep I
think we're good
everybody's outside I'm here all weekend
yeah so yeah as as men said if you have
anything later on just find him and talk
more Jupiter and I think thank you